I would say in like the the pantheon of
Super Bowls Steelers Cardinals was like
one of the greatest most exciting games
I've ever seen
you ended that Super Bowl so like take
me through the play man like that was
nuts
you know it was like we had a timeout
before and I remember coach Tyler put me
inside like whoo we need a big play you
know that's the kind of you see on TV in
the movie like come on man we need a big
play from you like I'm gonna make no big
play like all right coach you know I got
you you know they got a Larry Fitzgerald
toddlers receiver out there at the time
Kurt Warner can throw the ball yeah
so the best thing to do is to stop the
ball like in basketball just about the
guy with the ball so I'm Robin rushing
and Kurt Warner's looking at me son as
he as I went out he did thin so I dipped
out and I seen Kurt reaching back and I
just kind of like Superman Superman
didn't hit the ball out sac force foam
will break he's a jump on the ball
there's probably two moments for the
crowd goes nuts right one when you smack
it out and then like the realization
afterwards you know it didn't feel real
at first going into that game we felt
like we was gonna win anyway so I
already have my camera on a sideline
what do you mean you brought a camera
now at the hats I snuck it a little bit
knocking on your Jersey just look it
over through so what are you doing like
selfies yeah I was recording ugh and
I've never break heels accident instead
of Marvin you want the football I said
nah man keep it why did the help he
caught me at an exciting time I had a
good teammate yeah it's a this thing I'm
still trying to get that damn bar back
now don't get over if I ever got was
awesome take you to steal youngster rat
bread hide the vault under that roof